I also think that marvel is on this
journey now of their trying a bunch of
other stuff and it lets you know I'm
excited for them to see how all that
goes and it's hard to it's hard to
project now there are so many rumors
still out there fan theories people want
to see Ironman come back could it ever
happen yeah anything could happen
I'm really enjoying and all these
wonderful things looking right down the
barrel I'll be 3,000 welcome back
everyone is Charlie this is gonna be my
new video about Iron Man returning to
the Marvel movies eventually we've
actually found out when he's coming back
and obviously Robert Downey jr. in that
clip talks about coming back in a much
bigger way so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos we're doing a movie ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about Iron Man coming back on
the video so during that clip Robert
Downey jr. is basically saying he's open
to returning anything could happen he's
enjoying seeing all the different things
that Marvel and Kevin Feige are trying
to remodel phase 4 he wants to see how
that goes especially the Disney plus
Avengers spin-off series the weirder
stuff like the Eternals movie the new
Fantastic Four and x-men movies that's
what he's talking about when he says
Marvel is quote-unquote trying some new
stuff so really the Fantastic Four the
x-men the Deadpool stuff those are the
big-ticket items that are gonna be very
different than what you would have
expected from the MCU a couple years ago
I will talk about where I want to see
him come back but the really cool thing
is is we already found out that he
really is coming back as Iron Man
during Marvel phase 4 he's already
confirmed to be coming back for a new
project you may have also heard Kevin
Feige talking about getting him to come
back at various points during the
history of the MCU and their big movie
plans changed because it wasn't always a
done deal for instance that he was going
to be in Captain America Civil War so
when they were coming up with the idea
for Captain America Civil War they were
riding it as two or three different
types of movies because they didn't know
if they were gonna get spider-man and
they didn't know if they were gonna get
Robert Downey jr. is Iron Man
so the Russos and the writers Markus and
McFeely were just a couple doors down
from Kevin Feige offices inside the
Marvel Building and he would run in
every once in a while and say I think we
got Robert Downey jr. I think we're
gonna be able to use
Iron Man is the backdoor villain then
sometimes a couple days after that he
say I don't think we're gonna be able to
get Robert it's not looking good we
might have to find somebody else to be
the villain to this movie so there's
been a lot of times when Robert Downey
jr. has been on the fence about coming
back it all just depends on the right
script to the right role at the right
time so here's my top 5 picks for movies
and cameos to bring Robert Downey jr.
back as Iron Man inside the MCU in new
projects starting with number 5 this is
the one that he's confirmed already be
coming back for Iron Man has been
confirmed to be coming back for the
Avengers what if episodes during Marvel
phase 4 that's gonna be airing in the
next couple of years
Jeff Goldblum recently said that he had
already recorded some voiceover scenes
with Robert Downey jr. as their
characters I know a lot of you are
wondering which episode this is going to
be when would the Grand Master be
interacting with Iron Man they never met
each other on screen before it could be
for the Thor Ragnarok what-if episode
because why would the Grand Master
appear during an alternate version of
the events of the original Iron Man
movies even during Iron Man 3 the Grand
Master was nowhere near planet earth
there were some deleted scenes from
Avengers endgame with alternate routes
that the Avengers took when they were
going back to get the stones in one of
those alternate versions Iron Man teamed
up with Thor to go back to Asgard during
the events of Thor the dark world to get
the aether so if Iron Man is interacting
with the Grand Master they just could be
an alternate version of Thor Ragnarok
where Iron Man winds up on sacar somehow
or the Grand Master winds up coming back
to Planet Earth number 4 medium-term
next five years or so spider-man vs. the
sinister six say spider-man finds an
artificial intelligence backup of Iron
Man's consciousness you wouldn't need to
bring him back alive for this or even
bringing an alternate reality version
spider-man just has some unsolvable
problems in his fight against the MCU
version of Norman Osborn and the rest of
the sinister six the whole concept
behind doing a sinister six movie
eventually is that the villains working
together against spider-man who still
technically a teenager is just way too
much for him to handle by himself and it
needs some kind of boosts some help from
a science bro Voltron team up to defeat
them part of the reason why the
spider-man character is so great why
people love him so much is that he's
just this kid trying to be a hero just a
kid trying to make sense of it all it
makes them way more relatable than
someone like the
who's literally an alien God from
another planet who's been alive for more
than a thousand years so if you want to
think about Norman Osborn of the MCU
being something of an evil version of
Tony Stark
who better to help spider-man defeat his
evil genius than Iron Man himself at
least an artificial intelligence version
of Iron Man he would only need to be on
screen for 10 to 15 minutes with maybe a
couple minutes of voiceover scenes on
spider-man's coms
there was actually a version of this
that happened during spider-man far from
home but it wound up being a deleted
scene when spider-man first gets to eat
at the glasses on the bus originally
that was gonna be Iron Man's voice not
Edith's voice speaking to him and it was
gonna be this message saying that he's
passing the mantle here's these glasses
it was gonna be a more special version
of the I Love You 3000 moment from the
end of Avengers and game sort of him
saying a final good-bye and also telling
a couple wise crack jokes Tony Stark
style even dead I'm the hero it was
gonna be a little more literal than that
number three they bring him back for a
short cameo in the Fantastic Four movie
in a new version of the origin story for
the MCU Fantastic Four think of Reed
Richards is the newest smartest man on
the planet
he grows up goes through school inspired
by Tony Stark Iron Man in the Avengers
exploits and you find some way to weave
in some careful flashback scenes shot as
new footage integrating Tony Stark into
Reed Richards backstory
now the comic-book purists out there
will say that the Fantastic Four debuted
before Ironman in the comics so I'm kind
of expecting a fun way for them to
reference that in the new Fantastic Four
MCU origin story but I think we can all
agree that Reed Richards mr. fantastic
is probably one of the most important
new human characters that Marvel is
going to introduce in the next four
years next to people like Wolverine and
Professor X I know we talked about how
spider-man kind of inherited the mantle
of Iron Man in the MCU that was what the
glasses were all about during spider-man
far from home yes I totally think the
Spider Man is still gonna be one of
those people he could be a leader of the
Avengers but the deal with Sony makes
that kind of weird I still think that
he'll be around in the next six to eight
years though but it will require some
finesse with the Sony Marvel sharing
deal number two this is actually a fun
one bring Iron Man back for a Young
Avengers cameo in a time travel story so
this would be a version of Tony Stark
who's alive because you're using
time travel to go back into the past and
because they deleted that adult Morgan
Starks seen meeting Ironman during
Avengers end game you can still have a
scene where an adult version of Morgan
Stark eventually builds herself a suit
works with the Young Avengers and then
during that story they battle someone
like King the conquer Marvel's most
famous time-travel villain in Morgan
Stark goes back into the past
Avengers endgame style to get something
from the past and as some kind of
accidental run-in scene with her father
Tony Stark the same type of scene that
Iron Man got with his father in Avengers
endgame during the 1970s he wasn't
actually trying to meet his father he
accidentally bumped into him and they
used it as a really good opportunity but
that was the whole reason that the
writers wrote them going back to the
1970s because they wanted that moment
with his father to happen I know you so
you write a version of that for an adult
Morgan Stark and because it's
time-travel you can explain how she can
be with the young Avengers team because
right now Marvel has talked about doing
Young Avengers projects but if that
happens in the next couple of years if
you don't use time travel Morgan Stark
is still technically a really little
girl I did a whole video for that
Avengers and game deleted scene of them
meeting each other inside the soul world
after Ironman snapped his gauntlet so I
had a link to that at the end of this so
you could watch them together it's
really weird scene and they deleted it
before they finished the special effects
because they knew it wasn't gonna wind
up in the final cut of the film so this
is the visual effects artists abandoned
work on it pretty early in the process
in the number one way to bring him back
would obviously be to bring him back
alive from an alternate reality during
Avengers secret wars when you have a
bunch of alternate versions that the
characters start showing up and running
around on screen you could also use this
as a bigger payoff bigger crazier payoff
than what we'll see during the Avengers
what if Iron Man episodes think of the
most fanservice II amazing versions of
Iron Man showing up for a big battle
like the scene from the end of Iron Man
3 where all the armors show up to the
fight on the boat only because it's
super at Wars and you have all these
alternate reality versions of the
characters each one of the different
armors can be piloted by a different
version of Iron Man from different
realities and then they all go back to
their individual realities at the end of
the film but
everyone here's my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments what
movie or cameo do you want them to bring
Ironman back for and how do you want him
to come back as an AI time travel or
alternate reality my next big video is
gonna be my full Morbius trailer video
tomorrow morning as you can see here
this is Jared Leto's Morbius character
their literal spider-man references in
the background that's Tobey Maguire
spider-man suit but it's meant to be Tom
Hollands version I'll explain what the
heck is going on with that so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see that video when I post it
congratulations Omar Reyes you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for my Morbius teaser video
that leaked yesterday and click here for
that Avengers endgame deleted scene of
Iron Man meeting his daughter inside the
soul world thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]